in the process of creating applications
like google photos search gmail and maps
google has learned a lot about building
with ai and we're putting all that
know-how in your hands with google
cloud's ai apis so that you can easily
apply the best of what google has
learned to identify images transcribe
audio and understand context from
communication
each of these apis is powerful on its
own but what you might not know is just
how easy it can be to combine them to
build even more powerful and impressive
applications
[Music]
in this video we're going to see how you
can combine several apis together our
mission
extract sentiment from the spoken word
but we'll go a step further and create
the audio in the first place that means
we'll give you a taste of three
different apis
the text-to-speech api the
speech-to-text api and the natural
language api you ready let's dive into
the process for this example we're going
to be using python in a jupyter notebook
to run through a series of tasks let's
take it step by step so that you can see
what each part does
we'll start with a setup step to install
all the library dependencies we need to
run the code samples below we're
including dependencies for our
text-to-speech speech to text and
natural language apis let's run that
now we have a few global configurations
with this sample setup here i'll
highlight them as we use them
the next portion of our code is split
into three functions one for each of the
three apis that we'll be meeting in this
video the first function calls the text
to speech api to synthesize the audio
files i could just as easily have loaded
that speech sample from the cloud
storage bucket we made in my last api
video but since this episode is all
about combining apis
we'll use an api to create our audio
from scratch
once the audio is rendered we'll move on
to the next portion transcribing that
audio to text using the speech-to-text
api
by the way here's where we're using
those global settings from before to
tweak the operation of this api
yes we've gone from text back to text
but now you've seen just how easy it is
to combine two apis together
and now it's time to throw a third one
into the mix we'll take advantage of the
natural language api to isolate key
entities and get sentiment information
from our text
we'll use it to determine the general
tone positive or negative of entire
blocks of text and the key entities in
them
so
is it a happy story
let's run the code in the notebook first
we see that the audio has been rendered
in a playable control here
with the execution of our functions
let's give it a listen hey i want to
tell you that your employee janus was
super helpful today underneath that
control
we've transcribed text with annotations
about the sentiment at the beginning of
each phrase we see a printout of the
sentiment for the entire line
below each line we have character
underlines that show the sentiment
details about entities separate from the
sentiment for the entire line x is for
negative tildes for neutral and pluses
for positives now you've seen how easily
these apis work together and you're
empowered to start creating your own
complex workflows
if you have a system that handles voice
calls and you want to transcribe and
analyze that data you might use the
second set of apis with just a few lines
of code you can enable voice control for
all manner of systems giving you simple
and hands-free control over your tools
by using speech-to-text wanna translate
from another language toss in the
translate api to easily transcribe audio
and video streams into other languages
for captions accessibility and easy
searching to go even further you can use
models trained on domain specific
quality requirements for example if
you've recorded your audio at an
unusually low rate there you have it in
just a little bit of code we combined
multiple apis into a much more complex
task and brought nlp insights to audio
files head over to our google cloud
homepage and try it out yourself today
free of charge
[Music]